[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con república
dominicana chile y uruguay son los
primeros países en américa latina' en
aplicar la tercera dosis de la vacuna
contra el kobe 19 dejando de lado el
pedido de la oms de no aplicarla hasta
tanto los países rezagados en la
vacunación hayan inmunizado a un
porcentaje de la población para hablar
sobre la tercera dosis y también la
equidad está con nosotros el doctor
oscar franco el epidemiólogo director
del instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
académico de harvard y también de la
universidad erasmo de rotterdam y
también por supuesto nuestro asesor
científico aquí en france24 doctor le
doy la bienvenida que tanto respaldo
científico y médico tiene la aplicación
de una tercera dosis países como israel
incluso uruguay ya han empezado a
aplicarla y eeuu podría empezar a
hacerlo en septiembre es realmente
necesario
científica y médicamente tenemos cada
vez más evidencia que respalda la
necesidad de una tercera dosis que
podría según cuánto dure la pandemia y
cuanto dejamos el coral virus
convertirse en un futuro en una cuarta
una quinta y una sexta
necesidad de un refuerzo las razones
principales por lo que necesitamos de
esa tercera dosis son dos la primera es
que el virus va cambiando y las
variantes de ahora son diferentes a los
variantes originales que se utilizaron
para desarrollar las vacunas así que las
vacunas defienden pero no de igual
manera contra estas nuevas variantes y
la segunda razón es que hemos visto cada
vez más investigaciones que confirman
que las defensas podrían empezar a
reducirse después de seguir después de
ocho meses de haber sido vacunados
principalmente a mayor edad y en
personas que tengan comorbilidades así
que lo más probable es que necesitamos
una tercera dosis para mantener las
defensas ahora la llegada a esta tercera
dosis sea también en medio de un llamado
de bab ms a permitir primero mayor
equidad en el reparto de las vacunas
principalmente en los países menos
favorecidos cuál es su opinión al
respecto
estamos siendo testigos de una gran
injusticia mundial vemos billones de
vacunas que se aplicaban en todo el
mundo un 88 por ciento casi 90 por
ciento se han aplicado en poblaciones
del g20 que son los 20 países más ricos
del mundo vemos como poblaciones en
europa en eeuu en el reino unido tienen
más del 50% de la población adulta ya
con la vacunación completa mientras que
en áfrica no llega ni al 2% entonces
estamos viendo que mientras que en unos
países es cutre quizás luego la
necesidad de una tercera dosis
muchas personas grandes poblaciones en
latinoamérica en áfrica aún ni siquiera
han recibido la primera vacuna entonces
vemos una inequidad enorme a nivel
global hablando de esta injusticia como
esto calificó como lograr una
distribución más justa para poner fin a
esta pandemia de kobe 19 es posible que
las canciones se alejen de la lógica de
yo primero en pro del bien común
sería lo ideal que sea factible que se
vaya a ocurrir en un futuro cercano va a
ser difícil y parece que aún no se
entiende que si el virus se deja
circular el nivel mundial pues la
pandemia va a durar más tiempo y vemos
como lo que sucedió en índia puede
ocurrir en cualquier parte del mundo lo
que estamos viendo con la variante delta
y lo vimos desde el principio con lo que
ocurría en buján que ocurrió en todo el
mundo entonces sería lo ideal
no sé cómo más convencer a las naciones
más ricas para que tengan una visión más
global y ojalá la organización mundial
de la salud y los programas como cobas
puedan tener más éxito en un futuro
cercano doctor rápidamente mucho se
hable a la tercera dosis pero qué pasa
entonces con aquellos inoculados con una
vacuna que con una sola dosis como la de
johnson and johnson por ejemplo ahora
necesidad de una segunda dosis en esos
casos
estás estudiando es posible lo más
seguro que las personas que ya tuvieron
una aplicación de la vacuna con ginseng
es posible que necesiten un segundo
refuerzo aunque no se sabe aún para
cuándo exactamente esto es lo que se
está estudiando entonces también estas
personas van a necesitar lo más seguro
un refuerzo en un futuro cercano
doctor y para finalizar con la
preocupación que genera el avance de la
variante del taxista de presión sobre
las farmacéuticas para desarrollar una
nueva versión de las vacunas
si se están desarrollando vacunas que
podrían cubrir no solamente la variante
de venta sino que podrían cubrir a todo
tipo de variantes de este coronavirus
incluso a todos los corona vídeos que
existen esto sería una nueva tecnología
sería un nuevo un nuevo tipo de vacunas
que se están desarrollando pero que aún
no tenemos al mercado y que ojalá ojalá
a finales de este año oa principios del
próximo ya lo podamos ver ya con una
forma más concreta y ya disponible para
la para el uso en la población general
pues doctor gracias por su tiempo y por
supuesto por estar siempre con nosotros
aquí en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto de ustedes es continúa con
nosotros porque mucho más para ver aquí
en nuestro canal
[Música]